[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
みなさんは子どものころ将来何になりたいと思っていましたか
私はドクター原因乗りたいと思っていました
あもちろん患者ではありませんよ
私が今関わっている子どもたちの
将来に関するこの質問に対する反応はある程度年齢で異なります
小学生は宇宙飛行士
歴史家プロてに選手などとはっきりと表現をします
では中学生はどうでしょうか
いやー舌に
特に何もないですという具合です
しまいにはとりあえずお金持ちになればなんでもいいですって言う人もいます
でも私はこんな家の中が少し寂しいなと思いました
確かに中学生の方がより現実的に将来のことを考え始める証拠かもしれませんが
もしかしたらそれ以上に
教育の家庭で子どもたちの主体性をそいでしまっているのではないかなと思い始めた
からです
では似たような言葉に自主性積極性という言葉がありますが
主体性とは何でしょうか
みなさんはこれらの言葉をどう区別して使い分けますか
細かな違いですが私は自主性でも積極性でもなく主体性を使います
これらを比較してみるとまず
主体性と自主性の区別は
行動の目的を自分なりに考えているかどうかです
例えば部活デー
自分から大きな声で挨拶をする理由がチームの活性化のためになると自分なりに考えて
いるとすれば
主体的ですが
マグとして大事だから自分から大きな声で挨拶をするのであれば
自主的となります
次に
主体性と積極性の違いは
他からの影響の有無です
他人から勧められたものに積極的に取り組むといいますが他人から勧められたものに
主体的に取り組むとは言えません
ではこれらを踏まえると学校現場は主体的でしょうか
授業ではその日の宿題内容が決まっており
部活の練習メニューも大抵顧問が決め
引退活動も毎年恒例の業務を踏襲することが多いです
ではもしここに主体性が加わったらどのような良いことがあるでしょうか
私は大学受験の際世界一チームの3科目で受験をする必要がありました
しかし高校で対応できるのは世界史のみでチリは独学をしないといけませんでした
予備校に通っていなかった私はショー的な参考書と問題集を何度も何度も繰り返し
わからないことはインターネットてより専門的な参考書に頼りました
そう聞くといやーそれは大変そうだなと思われるかもしれませんが
こうして自ら学ぶことは受動的な授業よりもいっそう楽しく
一番充実した勉強時間でした
さらにセンター試験の結果も高校で2年間を授業を受けた
世界史が94点だったのに対しチリは95点でした
もちろん
科目性質や私との相性もあったかもしれませんが主体的に学ぶことの重要性を体感し
ました
このような主体性を子どもが自分ひとりで見つけることは非常に難しいと思います
そして私は子供たちが痴態的になるために大人がどのような支援を行えるか考え始め
ました
そんな中今年2020年
3月から5月まで
新型コロナウイルス感染症の影響で全国の小中高校が休校になるという出来事が起こり
ました
当初子どもたちは行っ砂丘コーダーと喜ぶ人たちもいましたが
大人は自宅体型の子どもへの教育機会の損失に大きく頭を抱えました
事実学校での学習時間がなくなった分
子供の学習時間は大幅に入りました
そうしたなか大学が始まらず時間的になった私たちは
フリーでケーションという団体を立ち上げボランティアで学習支援を行いました
もっと多くの子供たちが学ぶことが楽しい
学ぶことが大切だと気づき主体性を持って学ぶ習慣が身につけばこんな情勢でも
自ら学ぶことができたのではないか
また
そんな子どもたちをも宿ですからどれだけ日本の教育が発展するだろうかとワクワクし
ました
私たちは
子どもたちの主体性を高めるための方法の一つとして
補助輪をテーマにしています
皆さんも子どもの頃を思い出してみてください
補助輪は
初めて自転車に乗る子どもたちの支えとなりますが
子どもの発達段階に応じて徐々に調節され
伊豆へはなくなります
今でも補助輪をつけて自転車に乗る大人は滅多に見ませんよね
全く同じように
最初こそ手厚く支援を施し
子どもの発達段階に応じて徐々にその支援を減らし
いずれは子どもだけで実装できることが理想です
実際私たちフリーズケーションでは
オンラインで毎週土曜日
小学校1年生から中学校3年生主な対象に
自習室のホームルームをかけましたオンラインスクールを開催しています
今回はそこで実践している後処理のうち3つをご紹介したいと思います
一つ目は
その日の学習内容学習量自分自身で決めることです
まずは自分がやりたい
やるべきだと思うものに取り組みます
でもそんなことをしたら子どもたちは宣言する学習量を減らしてしまうのではないかと
思われるかもしれませんが
最後の振り替えの時間に頑張った分だけ
大学生がパックさんを見てくれるので子どもたちは一生懸命に頑張ります
もちろん大人になったら必ずしも
自分のための努力だけで
周りが褒めてくれるとは限りませんが
初期の段階では一生懸命頑張ることの重要性を伝えるためにたっくさん埋めることも
補助輪です
二つ目は発達段階に合わせた特別なようです
みーちゃんという小学校1年生の女の子がいますがその木場
間違えた問題に
罰をつけることがとにかく嫌でえっ
よく消しゴムでこっそり直して丸に書き換えていました
しかし間違えた問題を広くとして残すことも大切です
みなさんなら
こんなみーちゃんにどう対応しますか
私は
ねぇねぇみーちゃんまるにしてもいいけど part マークも付けてもらっていいと
提案をしました
するとみーちゃんはハートマークが大好きなので一生懸命にハートを書きその後も
間違えた問題があるためにハートマークつけるね
ハートマークつけるねハートマークつけるねと自分から言ってくれます
こうした特別対応
同じ団体にいる中学生にはしません
最終的に間違えた問題に罰をつけることは恥ずかしくないんだと理解してもらうことが
理想ですが
小学校1年生のみーちゃんへの対応は
手厚い補助輪から始まってもいいのではないでしょうか
3つ目は
大学生プチ講義ですそもそも自分たちがどうして主体的に勉強できるようになったのか
を考えたときそれは教科書の枠内にとどまらない
探求の楽しさを知ったこともその一つでした
しかし義務教育段階の子供たちにとっての大人は
家族先生近所の一つに限られそうした探求に出会う可能性は極めて低いです
そこで私たち恩来大学生の出番です
子どもたちが2時間ほど次週頑張った後大学生がリーダーシップ
法律学主は医療現場
激し額などの自分の趣味や専門分野について30分ほど抗議をします
普段接している目線の違い大学生が楽しそうに話す内容が
きっと子どもたちに大きな刺激を与えています
近い将来
小さい頃面白い大学生が法律について教えてくれてもっと法律を勉強したいんです
なんて言ってくれたらなと思います
将来何になりたいという質問に
いやー特に何もないぞ
という答えから日本中の子どもたちがキラキラした目で夢を飾ってくれる社会にしたい
です
ご静聴ありがとうございます